ah
[Aplausos]
apasionado por los perros andaba por las
calles de las niñas
y cuando se dio cuenta había un perro
atado un pase con agua y comida entonces
él lo pensó y dijo lo voy a adoptar
le puso allí y lo llevó a su casa
pasaron mucho tiempo jugando o
disfrutando hasta que el señor mal
decidió casarse
y se casó con la señora emma
y tuvieron dos hijos clave ya no estén
como el señor mike ya no podía mantener
a high y él lo fue a dejar un donde le
encontró en la calle de las minas atado
un poste con agua y comida
y se fue
entonces cada vez que pasaba alguien
parecido al señor mike casi lloraba qué
harías tú si te encontrarás en la
situación del señor
sabes cuántos perros en situación de
abandono hay actualmente
en el 2013 la unidad son francisco de
quito conjunto con el colegio de
ciencias biológicas ambientales la
cohesiva
desarrolló un proyecto iniciativas para
el control de animales line camp realizó
este censo y le dio una cifra de 41 mil
676 perros de la calle
mientras que en el 2019 realizó este
mismo censo y le dio una cifra
122 mil 200 perros en la calle dándonos
cuenta que
en seis años la cifra aumentó a 88 mil
600 perros en la calle
en cuenca hay 90.000 perros de esos 15
mil son abandonados eso quiere decir que
2 de cada 10 perros
estando en la calle
y a nivel nacional hay
6 millones de perros en la calle
dándonos cuenta que 4 millones tiene el
dueño
sabe su expectativa de vida
la expectativa de vida de un perro que
come bien y se lo cuida bien es de 15 a
17 años
mientras de un perro que a veces con ya
a veces no es de 5 a 7 años
se les ha ocurrido adoptar a uno de
estos dos millones de perros en la calle
yo adoptado se llama tom y la adoptamos
en el 2017 cuando tenía a mercury cougar
cumplir 10 años justo un día antes de mi
cumpleaños el 8 de octubre de 2017
le pusimos tommy porque cuando lo íbamos
a adoptar
era muy travieso como en todo mi ser
actualmente tiene un año y cuando llegó
a casa era muy dormilón
y mordía mucho ahora ha crecido mucho
casi ya no duerme y hace sus travesuras
pueden darse cuenta que yo adoptado a un
perrito y le ha podido dar hogar
y ha podido disminuir un perro de esta
cantidad
además
los perros de la calle son únicos porque
los perros de raza como por ejemplo el
golden es
de color café crema u oro mientras un
perro de la calle es de muchos colores y
de varios tamaños de igual manera mambo
que era un perro que estaba en la calle
y una fundación no conoció hasta que
encontrara familia
sobrevivió a un volcán de indonesia
y cuando encontró familia recuperó su
buen estado de salud y de ánimo
no sólo nosotros ayudamos a ellos siendo
ellos también nos pueden ayudar a
nosotros como por ejemplo te hacen
sentir más seguro ya que te protegerán
ante cualquier peligro te hace sentir
más feliz ya que ellos saben cómo sacar
tu niño interior
y te hace recuperar tu buena salud
física ya que quieras solo tendrás que
sacarlo a pasear les propongo que
pensemos de esto
cuando tú compras a un perrito es como
si fueras a comprar a un niño mientras
que si tu adoptar un perrito es como si
fueras a un mall bánato adoptar así no
fomentaremos la compra venta de animales
muchos dicen que los perros son el mejor
amigo del hombre pero para ellos no sólo
eres un mejor amigo eres su familia ya
que no te fijaste en su aspecto
siento en lo que él te quería dar por
eso les digo nunca la abandones porque
nunca te va a abandonar gracias
y
[Música]